it would be an absolute uh
abnegation of duty if he conceded right
now there is no reason to do it
the the process will have to play out in
the courts joe biden by the way
was going to do this same thing if
somehow the machines worked differently
and joe biden were the one who were down
a little bit right now you know that he
would be
pushing this in courts he hired 600
lawyers to litigate this
a few months ago hillary clinton said
that joe biden should concede under no
circumstances
including a clear trump victory so no i
don't think donald trump
should concede do you remember the 2000
presidential election
do you remember bush vigor al gore who
had no case by the way his case was so
weak
it was only in one state and there was
no evidence of fraud
al gore dragged that process out for 38
days
what are we in right now day five or
something like that
day six no way should president trump
let this go
in fewer than 38 days the
liberals right now and the concerned
troll
foe conservatives are in this push for
trump to concede
in in the name of healing and patriotism
and dignity
give me a break there's nothing
dignified in rolling over
when we have evidence of at least
certain
illegal actions that harmed the
integrity of our election
at least in philadelphia a crucial state
no way but of course the squishes
want to come out and concede the
election on trump's behalf so
jeb jeb jeb
yeb i think is is how you say it two
exclamation points
he tweeted out quote congratulations to
president-elect biden
i have prayed for our president most of
my adult life
i will be praying for you and your
success now is the time to heal deep
wounds
many are counting on you to lead the way
i think it's perfectly right to pray
for the president the current president
donald trump
and for his opponent joe biden it's good
to pray for those who persecute you it's
good to pray
for the crooked election workers in
philadelphia even
doesn't mean we need to roll over an
acquiesce to their nefarious actions or
pretend
that joe biden is the president-elect
when he's not
something tells me jeb bush did not vote
for donald trump just a hunch
something tells me he may have very
likely voted for joe biden
so this is not this is now being
portrayed in the media as this wonderful
graciousness from that republic and that
conservative jeb bush
how wonderful we should all follow his
example i don't think so i think jeb
bush is very likely
happy that that joe biden may have
beaten donald trump i guess we just
don't know we're going to find out later
and fair enough jeb bush took it pretty
hard from donald trump
probably without jeb there's no
president trump because
jeb was the foil for president trump so
i get it the guy has a personal beef
with him okay
doesn't mean the rest of us should roll
over mitt romney same goes for him
mitt romney tweets out ann and i are
extend our congratulations
to president-elect joe biden and vice
president-elect kamala harris
we know both of them as people of
goodwill and admirable character
we pray that god may bless them in the
days and years ahead yeah i pray that
god may bless them too i
as we as we all do i pray for all these
miserable sinners that we see here on
earth
ourselves included however
we don't congratulate these people as
the president and vice president-elect
because
they are not yet that thing i love this
idea we know both of them as people of
goodwill and admirable character
joe biden is the most notorious liar in
the united states
and he has been since 1988 when he had
to drop out of the election for
lying joe biden said that donald trump
is a racist he started his campaign on a
lie the lie that
trump called nazis fine people at
charlottesville never happened put that
one away with the tooth fairy and the
easter bunny it simply isn't true
joe biden lied and and slandered a man
who was involved in that tragic car
accident that involved joe biden's wife
but he lied about it
the man it haunted him his whole life
there was no evidence that the man had
done anything wrong was just a terrible
accident
and yet after the man died joe biden
said he was a drunk driver
vicious vicious pathological lies
i i don't think joe biden's a
particularly good guy i think joe biden
sues nuns
and he's going to sue nuns again he's
promised to do it because they won't pay
for abortion drugs i think joe
joe biden supports abortion on demand
taxpayer-funded i don't think he's a
good guy at all
and frankly i don't think mitt romney is
a very good guy we have this line on the
right where we say
oh mitt romney poor mitt he was so
maligned
in 2012 in particular by joe biden who
said that mitt romney wants to put black
people in chains
neither here nor there oh poor mitt he
was such a good man
what a good man mitt was and he was so
his character was besmirched by the
democrats
how is he a good man he's another
he's another notorious liar in politics
he flip-flopped on every single issue
his whole life he always went for
expediency when he was running for
senate against
teddy teddy kennedy he said that he was
not a republican during the time of
reagan bush he completely disavowed
ronald reagan
and pretended to be an independent he
described himself as very pro-choice
and defended abortion he though then he
invented obamacare remember that when he
invented obamacare
and then he attacked an actual
conservative who ran for president
donald trump
even after groveling for his endorsement
in 2012. i don't think mitt romney is a
particularly good guy either i think
i've had enough
of this idea that donald trump is this
awful terrible man with so many unique
character flaws
not like those good people you know mitt
romney give me a break
i'm not saying donald trump is pure as
the newly driven snow
but frankly i think he's much more
honest and has greater political
humility than any of these clowns
and so no i don't think we need to
follow their wonderful gracious example
the romney problem really drives me nuts
i have to tell you that was another one
i don't want to say i told you so
don't want to say i was nostradamus here
however
i had mitt romney's number from the very
beginning back in 2012 i worked for two
of mitt romney's primary opponents
because i knew it was going to be a
complete disaster as the republican
nominee
and probably not a very good president
if he got elected and
i that was absolutely correct i hope you
enjoyed that short segment from the
michael knowles show be sure to check
out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you